[Music]
hey guys welcome back to you know you
know oh you know if you know this mean I
don't know and today we're gonna be
talking about our parents the
relationship between us and our parents
it [ __ ] I think is the first time we
tripped on the CC man we always have a
[ __ ] reason and children conscripts
that console relatable no conscripts and
concubines [ __ ] get further away from
the family aspect so I've been trying to
work on my relationship with my mom yeah
and as you guys know the relationship
that I have my mom it's usually really
trollee cuz I think it's just me being
passive-aggressive and trying to get
back at her for all the times she
opposed everything I want to do in my
life and now that I have the upper hand
in life like I try to throw everything
back in her face but then now these days
I'm like man if I want to improve my
relationship with my mom which is the
ultimate goal I can't constantly troll
her so I keep that down to once a week
and then the net the other three to five
times during the week when we text back
and forth
I try to be much more understanding and
try to see where she's coming from our
where's your ideal relationship with
your mother my ideal relationship would
be I don't know if it's impossible
because of the way her mind is but it
would be awesome if we could talk about
just regular things without me feeling
like I'm being lectured you know and we
can just discuss things as if we're
friends how do you talk to Joe without
feeling like you're being lectured not a
white girl so it's pretty easy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
now we're cooking with fire boys
Pat what's your relation here with your
friends it's actually really good to
think of pad to least Bart and like a
lot of people I think I'm really close
with both my parents I could tell them
like anything and they'd come to me
actually to like if they have problems
with them like each other you know then
they'll come to me and kind of say oh
they'll use you as the middle ground
yeah yeah will they fight through you
pretty much where does your pain come
from them
my what where's your pain come from
myself most people that relate to this
group there's some sort of pain right
like like that's why you like this kind
of group of misfits like what throw some
[ __ ] he told me he's like that like my
parents they [ __ ] have to work hard
they take a lot of [ __ ] from the
siblings and that's why I want to make a
lot of money so I could [ __ ] retire
there's pain come from the siblings so
that's why I say oh but the
responsibility that he puts on himself
as a young man the youngest boy right
you're the middle no middle boy and then
the fight I'm like that's a that's a
responsibility your older siblings
should take on and he's trying to
[ __ ] ball hard so he could retire as
parents and work I'm like damn dude
that's a that's a pretty bold move to
make that is what pain do you derive
from your sibling um I don't know none
of us get along with each other I think
and I think how many of you guys are
there there's five of us total yeah and
I think my parents kind of blamed
themselves for being too horny I don't
know it's like for us to not like get
together you know I think they think
it's their fault that you guys don't get
along with each other yeah that's a lot
of people to make get along with each
other
I don't get along though like is their
core even though it's not all my
siblings are there you get mad at me
first because it lasts my did a podcast
with Joe my brother got mad it's Brandon
okay my bad my viola
what's your brother's name I'm not gonna
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
he doesn't want the family drama to be
aired out yeah I brought it up I brought
it up though because I I don't know I
just heard you know like we all kind of
relate cuz we all have family issues
right like we go out there and we hang
out with other people and it seems like
they don't [ __ ] have issues and I
can't relate with them but I think
that's how we all kind of came together
as a group in JK we like each other more
than we like our [ __ ] family
sometimes yeah dude I got new hugest
argument with my brother that I've ever
had recently because he even used
manscape but you can go to right now oh
my god it's an ad brand Craig [ __ ]
segue by the way yeah you could you get
the the device 43.0 thank you yeah I
used to have the same relationship with
Bart with how he had had with his
parents they were soulful you fixed a
lot of your your family stuff recently
right are you Nate oh man big time but
also it's it's their work too like they
have their own self development journey
and like my mom um you know she was
never able to take criticism but I think
just over the years in me being such a
[ __ ] hard-ass she was pressed to look
at herself
that's great yeah and then obviously
your dad's does that's good suspicion
he's dead confirmed
I'm scared a [ __ ] text back no so so
what am I supposed to text I don't know
no how are you is he alive
ok so this is what I think happened ok
so he's living with his girlfriend right
and we've been texting back and forth
and I texted him an article that they
wrote about me in Japanese and I was
like did you see this yet and then I get
a text that says no Richard so I'm like
did this [ __ ] die no less than a week
ago by the way yeah you need to follow
up on that what am I gonna say like well
last time he last time he called I was
like oh [ __ ] you didn't die and he's
like yeah he's like I'm gonna live I'm
like so tell me what's going on with
your dialysis and he's like well I you
know now I could do it at home and I'm
feeling much better because he used to
go to a center to get
three times a week all right good all
right I was like well well how much life
you got right like you just checking his
watch
like I mean leg three oh we got three
bars you know the doctor says that I
like someone found like a liver
transplant this and that he goes I think
I'm gonna go to surgery soon and I was
like okay that's cool so we left it at
that and then I got sick remember for
like a whole month and he wanted to meet
up and collaborate on some music and
[ __ ]
because he's a singer and a piano player
so we were just gonna jam out and
whatever and then um after that it was
it was I didn't hear from him for a week
so I texted him and then it just said it
basically no Richard I would have
thought of me like what the [ __ ] do you
mean that after this video genuinely
terrified to know the truth right cuz
I'm like you would rather leave it in
limbo though this wasn't limbo for so
long
well yeah cuz no no cause here's the
thing is like I'm about to go on a trip
and I rather be blind Oh
the owner when I get back usually being
a limo his old man he was that deaf for
ten years
well he she could have been dead so that
to me it's more comfortable than to
knowing the truth I'll be in Europe
sightseeing and I [ __ ] enjoy it's not
on the back of my mind like using the
die again but here's the thing though my
experience with them is completely
different what I realized is when people
when I talk about my parents in whatever
luring people are referring back to
their own experience and all at all and
I'm like honestly I lived 20 plus years
of my life without him so I lived more
life without him so yeah there is some
memory but to me having that experience
I haven't even talked about this but I
did we kind of like you know we caught
up and we became friends and stuff like
that and we became and to me all of that
is just extra so since I've made that
closure already it's almost like I'm
having friendship with a ghost okay so
it's a different same thing with my
grandma as soon as she got Alzheimer's I
was like this [ __ ] dead
so I had her for an extra 10 years so I
was like every single year after that I
was like oh great like I get to have my
friend time with Casper
he had a bonus grandma bonus grandma
that's that's how I see my grandma was
she had Alzheimer's too and shake it for
another 10 my mom was holding on to her
and I was like mom like let her go this
is extra credit like she's done like
she's gone won't make any new memories
right and my mom's fighting with her
she's not gonna make any my mom's
fighting with her right she's like up
until a couple years ago my mom would
fight with my grandma as if she
remembers and I'm like you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's when I realized how dumb my
mom was well that's different though
because she's spending every day with
her mom right you're only on the grandma
every now and then so of course she's
gonna fight yeah but also I explained to
her she has a disease and she doesn't
have the capability to memorize although
I guess yeah yeah it is it is
frustrating yeah hey dude I hung out
with Nikki's Alzheimer grandma and that
was [ __ ] nuts
like she hit on me the entire time weird
but then she also said [ __ ] like it icky
and a giddy giddy you know what the [ __ ]
you say and then like it was a college
football game on and she thought it was
like the Olympics yeah now the sharp as
a knife though she's university educated
she's [ __ ] smart she hides the fact
that she forgets she can have a
conversation with you she'll debate you
all that stuff and she'll ask the same
question in three minutes
Wow but then she's too proud to say I
forgot that oh dude Nicki's grandma like
smelled like a lady who doesn't remember
she was how to walk she yeah so she you
won't be able to tell that she has
Alzheimer's I think that's probably why
my mom they didn't register it and I'm
all like she has it she's asking the
same question my mom's like you know
this information why are you asking this
[ __ ] and I'm all like dude she has
Alzheimer's what the [ __ ] my grandma is
way different she'd be like who left
their teeth here
damn
take a pedophile mouth of you like oh
dude my grandma if my gran was there for
that she turned to me like I hate old
people dude my grandma did that too when
we went to go visit different homes
right she was like this is lame like why
do I want to be with these old people
cuz dude I think there's a certain age
where you don't feel like you're aging
anymore and I think that legit even old
people feel like they're 28 yeah and so
they they don't get seen as 28 ever but
they think the 28 and I could have
encountered this when I was recently
with always tick-tock kids at playlist
live and I'm like you guys you know hey
guys what's going on and the hunters
leave immediately and they're like how
do you fellow youth I'm the old guy you
don't say yeah you don't you don't think
of it in the moment we just experienced
the old guy thing we went to Austin and
we spoke at the University right and it
we didn't register that it was nine
years ago that we spoke at the same
school oh wow completely different you
know body of students and all that stuff
and then afterwards they were asking us
questions and then the [ __ ] that hit me
was like hey so one of the students were
like so
Barton Joe um when it comes to adults
like you guys in your generation versus
the kids like us in our generation do
you see a difference and I'm like what
did you just say [ __ ] you say to me kid
you said to my face come on stay to
fight me huh that's my face little [ __ ]
what difference in generation wait what
what the [ __ ] yeah because I consider
ourselves the same generation but they
don't clearly don't see it that way 10
years older than I said you just like
not only 10 we're like 15 Oh
so if you think about it I was like holy
crap I know dad is an age gap I am an
adult what the [ __ ] happened I was on a
bus with you guys know what Jordan Jones
is no she's a very young influencer
person I say no does that mean a hole
doesn't matter she was in my movie she's
in my movie internet-famous
when she was like 14 15 years old and
now she's like 19 oh no and I was like
we were all outside of a bus yesterday
waiting to get on on
to it after playlist live is over and
like I looked at her and her like little
boyfriend he's like a tiny man - and
yeah they're both very tiny people I
don't know I'm dad [ __ ] its Explorer
nobody's 6 foot even so I'm like I see
everyone's tiny and so I was like hey
I'm everyone you're my movie Internet
family she's like I'm like this feels
like I'm talking to an elf not weird
I felt weird just even saying that out
loud I remember near my movie it's like
man this is a young person I should not
be here yeah yeah the two 40s are
double-fisting it seems inappropriate no
right I should have been a Coco's for an
early bird special or some phone
[Music]